as our top story tonight Henry Cavill
and the mystery over Superman now of
course you mean the Man of Steel II blue
eyes yeah lost its mind over the report
that he had lost the role which made him
famous but cavil appears to be pushing
back in a quirky new Instagram post
Henry Cavill holds up a Superman action
figure possibly sending a message that
he's not giving up the role yet the
response comes after a story in The
Hollywood Reporter claimed that cavil is
out as the Man of Steel today though we
have learned what may have sparked all
the speculation cow bells cameo as
Superman in the upcoming superhero film
Shazam was scrapped because he was busy
filming Mission Impossible fallout still
cabals post isn't stopping new casting
rumors deadline is now reporting that
Black Panther star Michael B Jordan is
being considered as cabals replacement
meanwhile there's also report that Ben
Affleck is hanging up his cape as Batman
oh my god it's such a pain in the ass
it's like every time I mention Batman it
gets this huge you know clickbait gonna
do it good we're gonna do it the right
way we reached out to Ben's rep for
comment on the Batman story and have not
heard back but get this actor Jon Hamm
is definitely interested I'm a huge
comic book fan I always have them the
former Mad Men star just hold in depth
with grin Benziger he'd sign on if the
script were right i price fit the suit
yes
I have to work out a lot I don't love
but I mean you know a lot of people have
to sign off on that obviously
you